[Música]
bienvenidos nuevamente a ella soy de
france de 24 la prostitución es el único
mecanismo de supervivencia para miles de
mujeres en el mundo desprotegidas por el
estado y víctimas de un ciclo de
violencia del que dependen para tener
ingresos en pandemia sus derechos
humanos ya vulnerados por la naturaleza
de su actividad quedan invisibilizados y
al reto de sobrevivir al abuso del
tráfico humano se suma el temor por un
virus y por no poder trabajar quien les
ayuda a estas mujeres y en qué debe
enfocarse este apoyo cuando el abuso la
explotación y el maltrato físico son la
realidad en un oficio que está basado en
el tráfico con el cuerpo femenino veamos
la prostitución es una forma de
violencia producto de la carencia de
opciones y de la falta de protección del
estado que no puede garantizar los
derechos humanos y el coi 19 lo empeora
todo en colombia' antes de la pandemia
estas mujeres luchaban por ganarse la
vida en la calle o en burdeles ahora
dependen de escasos ahorros o de la
caridad y ninguno es suficiente en una
situación de pobreza y abandono el único
recurso de seguir arriesgando la vida en
la calle y al temor de las violencias
machistas se suma el miedo al contagio
oa las sanciones policiales por estar en
la vía pública
mis ahorros se han acabado porque nada
toca comprar mi comida todos los días
todos los días salgo a la calle a
comprar mi comida con miedo que se me
pegue esa enfermedad y no podré salir a
trabajar
las mujeres que también son cuidadoras y
proveedoras pasan hambre y con ellas sus
hijos y familias
fidelia suárez presidenta del sindicato
de trabajadoras sexuales de colombia
recibe pedidos de auxilio todos los días
entre más de 2 mil afiliados que no
pueden pagar comida ni alquiler
estamos pidiendo auxilio a aquellos
corazones a nivel mundial que nos puedan
aportar así sea desde un mercadito para
llevarle a nuestras compañeras que están
hoy en día comenzando a aguantar hambre
en la capital colombiana bogotá hay más
de 7000 mujeres en situación de
prostitución según un censo de 2017 no
existen cifras a nivel nacional ni
tampoco una política clara sobre cómo
ayudarlas especialmente cuando la
prostitución es una vía directa de
explotación sexual y proxenetismo
así las cosas hoy vamos a hablar de una
iniciativa que expone algunos de los
efectos ligados al ejercicio de la
prostitución y por eso nos acompaña la
abogada carolina sánchez vázquez ella es
líder de proyectos del colectivo [__]
mente poderosas carolina bienvenida a
ella soy yo
hola angela muchísimas gracias por la
invitación a ustedes bueno vamos a
empezar por la terminología ustedes
prefieren carolina a hablar de trabajo
sexual y no de prostitución rápidamente
porque
bueno porque hay una gran diferencia
entre hablar de trabajo sexual y de
prostitución y es que cuando hablamos de
trabajo sexual creemos que esta
actividad debe ser reconocida como esto
como un trabajo digno de colombia y para
eso es que tenemos como fundamento una
sentencia de la corte constitucional la
sentencia 3 629 de 2010 a partir de la
cual se reconoce como un trabajo digno
en colombia en el trabajo sexual creemos
que estamos frente al trabajo sexual
cuando hay libertad y voluntad de
quienes lo ejercen y en ese sentido se
deben reconocer los derechos laborales
de quienes ejercen bueno entonces vamos
a empezar a hablar de este tema tan
polémico que es la legalización porque
de ahí parte la forma en que los
colectivos feministas creen que se debe
apoyar a la mujer que está envuelta o
ejerciendo prostitución y entonces le
tendría que preguntar legalizar no sería
lo mismo que avalar o que legitimar una
situación que por definición implica el
abuso y la violación de los derechos
humanos
bueno entonces hay primera que hacen una
distinción y es que en colombia la
prostitución nunca ha sido una actividad
ilegal es una actividad lícita que está
permitida lo que pasa es que nunca ha
estado regulada el único fallo que
tenemos es a partir del 2010 como les
había comentado y ahí entonces lo que
nosotros creemos es que el camino de la
regulación porque porque cuando
regulamos esta actividad lo que estamos
es procurando que desde el estado se
garanticen los derechos de las personas
que lo ejercen nada conseguimos con
prohibir con sancionar con acabado una
actividad que históricamente nos ha
acompañado y que difícilmente va a
terminar de un día para otro con la
expedición de una ley que prohíba la
actividad yo creo que es un problema
estructural es un problema que tiene
muchas aristas problemas sociales
políticos económicos y sobre todo
culturales es una actividad arraigada la
cultura colombiana y creo que la
solución es empezar por reconocer eso
como una actividad digna y por la
reconocer las personas que lo ejercen
también como personas dignas y personas
que tienen derechos
claro en eso vamos a estar de acuerdo y
es que tiene que existir un
reconocimiento una dignidad y en
situaciones como la que vivimos ahora de
pandemia pues tiene que existir también
una ayuda y un apoyo para los frenos de
las actividades económicas sin embargo y
otra vez de tengo que hacer una pregunta
que para usted puede ser disruptiva y es
que en la legalización implica que estas
mujeres tendrían que entrar por ejemplo
a pagar impuestos por ejemplo a pagar
una ips o un seguro de salud para que
las cubra y estamos hablando de que en
el grueso de las mujeres que se dedican
a prostitución o trabajo sexual como
ustedes lo denominan pues tienen ya de
hecho muchas dificultades para ganar
dinero y entonces además van a tener que
entregar algo de dinero al estado y esto
no necesariamente va a implicar
protección porque como usted protege lo
que sucede detrás de una puerta
cuando muchas veces la prostitución está
ligada al proxenetismo está ligada al
abuso sexual oa la trata de personas
en qué punto esto se vuelve una
actividad digna cuando la prostitución
es tantas veces no una opción sino la
única opción que tiene una mujer
bueno lo que esa es una cara de la
moneda yo creo que se puede ver la
regulación de dos formas y es que doy
pero por el otro lado que recibo y es
que cuando hablamos de regular el
trabajo sexual estamos hablando que las
personas que mujeres en puedan tener
todos los derechos laborales que puede
tener cualquier trabajador eso que
implica implica el acceso al sistema de
seguridad social que como bien lo
mencionaba comprende la salud la pensión
y los riesgos laborales implica un
aporte mínimo por parte de del
trabajador de en este caso las
trabajadoras sexuales pero también un
apoyo del empleador aquí nos nos
situamos por ejemplo en los
establecimientos de comercio que son en
donde se ejerce gran parte del trabajo
sexual también implica que una serie de
acciones afirmativas es decir que el
estado reconozcan que las trabajadoras
sexuales son sujetos vulnerables y entre
a subsidiar parte de la salud por
ejemplo o de la pensión
es un tema que seguramente va a causar
mucha controversia en un país como
colombia pero que es necesario ahora por
ejemplo contamos en colombia con el
proyecto
colombia mayor en donde se subsidia una
parte de la pensión de poblaciones
vulnerables entonces digo en la pregunta
por qué no hacerlo con las trabajadoras
sexuales entonces es que ganamos
sí perdón que la interrumpa porque la
regla o la pregunta de por qué no
hacerlo con las trabajadoras sexuales
son las mujeres que ejercen prostitución
pues tiene todo el sentido que ellas
reciban todo el aporte y todo el apoyo
pero también está el otro lado que es la
idea la filosofía de las mujeres que son
abolicionistas y que dicen que la única
salida es terminar con la prostitución y
es porque no ayudarlas de otra manera
por ejemplo a que no tengan que ejercer
la prostitución como única opción de
supervivencia o única manera de recibir
ingresos pero bueno ustedes lo ven desde
el lado de la legalización ya que no ven
una opción en abolir esta actividad su
colectivo se llama [__] mente poderosas
y tengo que preguntarle ustedes utilizan
muchísimo la palabra [__] porque quieren
resignificar la quieren darle un sentido
diferente y a partir de eso generar una
acción de respeto
sí bueno ahí quisiera decir algo antes
de referirme al nombre del colectivo y
es que nosotros si bien apuntamos al
reconocimiento del caos sexual como un
trabajo la legalidad ya la legalización
respetamos la postura que cada una de
ellas pueda tener y en nuestras
actividades también procuramos unidad
actividades productivas alternas a
quienes deciden libremente no ejercer el
trabajo sexual yo creo que partimos de
esa posición de libertad 10 quienes lo
ejerzan en donde vamos a poder jugar a
luchar porque se reivindica su oficio y
se reconoció con trabajo pero quienes
libremente no lo quieren hacer está bien
decir bueno busquemos otras
oportunidades de trabajo frente entonces
la pregunta sobre [__] mente uno de
nuestros objetivos y lo que nos hemos
propuesto indicar la palabra [__] y es
que históricamente eso estaba asociado
con una mujer inmoral con una mujer
indigna y no y no eso no es una es una
[__] es una mujer que tiene r2 es una
mujer que ejerce un oficio como
cualquier otro y todo empieza desde el
lenguaje también uno de nuestros
objetivos y que lo hemos logrado mucho
ha sido incómoda
y es que llegar a espacios oficiales
llegar a espacios muy formales con estos
términos yo creo que nos ha permitido
ser un poco disruptivas al respecto
bien y finalmente esto implica el
ejercicio de la prostitución tráfico del
cuerpo femenino y algunos argumentos en
contra de esto es que hay una acción de
poder en la que lo que se legitima es
que el hombre tiene derecho a pagar por
tener sexo con una mujer y en
condiciones que finalmente en la mayoría
de casos no se van a cumplir porque algo
se pacta de puertas para afuera y algo
diferente puede suceder de puertas para
adentro entonces como cual es la
propuesta de ustedes para la protección
de las mujeres cuando es una actividad
que es tan peligrosa y que
potencialmente las convierte en uno de
los grupos con mayor posibilidad de
sufrir asesinato
sí bueno hay dos cosas yo creo que
hablan de tráfico del cuerpo es una
concepción todavía muy restrictiva de
intentado sexual ducto que debemos
hablar de la prestación un intercambio
de servicios de manera libre donde hay
dos personas que pueden llegar a estar
en la misma función que son el hombre la
mujer una prestando un servicio y lado y
el otro pagando por él sin embargo esto
no desconoce qué es que es un oficio
queda altamente peligroso en donde se
está está en riesgo la vida la
integridad y yo creo que hay es el
llamado y las acciones que nosotros
pretendemos y es generar rutas de
atención en general protocolos de
seguridad es generar confianza genera la
cercanía con la institucionalidad que
sea la fuerza pública por ejemplo un
aliado en un enemigo que se encuentra y
sobre todo pues una concientización del
respeto de la mujer y de la persona
bueno pues muchísimas gracias a usted
carolina de [__] mente de poder osasuna
un colectivo que está trabajando a su
manera para dignificar el trabajo sexual
y bueno quedado como reflexione el día
de hoy el pensar desde qué punto se debe
dignificar y cuál es la mejor manera que
tenemos para ayudar siempre a las
mujeres gracias a ustedes por estar con
nosotros sigan en ellas hoy y también en
france 24
[Música]